[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen im saal
israels heute gibt's schoko soufflé
einmal dunkel einmal hell und jogger so
viel habe ich schon mal zubereitet vom
grill ich weiss nicht aber ihr euch
erinnert und bei schokoladen soufflé ist
ja immer das geheimnis diesen perfekten
kern hinzubekommen dass da eben flüssig
ist und ich weiß es viele autoren mit
probleme haben dann ist das schoko
soufflé im kurzen moment länger im ofen
und dann zack ist das schoko so viel
nicht mehr flüssig also habe ich mir
gedacht zeige ich euch jetzt einen tipp
den habe ich nämlich aus der gastronomie
denn da wird auch geschummelt denn die
packen einfach in den schoko sushi in
choco soufflé einfach einen ghanas kern
rein also einen kern aus schokolade und
er ist halt immer flüssig egal wie lange
das soufflé im ofen war also gibt es
heute diesen tipp für euch und das heißt
ich werde jetzt erstmal eine ganache
erstellen und dieses schoko soufflé
masse und wie gesagt erst mal dunkel und
später hell und dann habt ihr gleich
zwei varianten und könnt euch immer
jederzeit in meiner app das soufflé
rezept anschauen und speichern und
jederzeit schokoladen sushi zubereiten
und vor allem könnt ihr das ganze gut
einfrieren und hab dann immer so viele
auf vorrat dann einfach kurz im backofen
oder auf dem grill und fertig für die
kanal nämlich 50 gramm sahne 40 gramm
heißen espresso 140 gramm zarter
schokolade und fürs zuviel jeweils 250
gramm butter und bitterschokolade
120 gramm zucker eine prise salz etwas
tonka pasta oder vanille extrakt und 100
gramm mehl ich geb dir zuerst mal die
sahne in ein gefäß und lasst sie auf
kochen gerne auch den espresso wenn ihr
keinen kaffeegeschmack haben wollt dann
lasst einfach weg und nimmt einfach ein
bisschen mehr sahne stopp dessen
dann kurz aufkochen lassen
dann schaltete den herd aus und gibt die
profiteure dazu und dann kurz rühren bis
sich alles verbunden hat und die
schokolade geschmolzen ist und dann darf
die garage erstmal aus kühl und weil es
einfach nicht ganz so dramatisch ist
werde ich dir jetzt gleich um füllen
damit ich einfach einen kalten keller
hat und eben ganz kurz kalt stellen die
kalt bis die so viel masse eben auch
bereit ist das heißt es hat sich zwar
immer so professionell und irgendwie
auch kompliziert an ist es aber gar
nicht geht wirklich ganz einfach
dann habe ich jetzt hier die botschaft
die werde ich gleich im topf schmelzen
und dann auch die kuvertüre darin
schmelzen aber die zeit kann ich immer
ganz gut überbrücken und kann jetzt die
eier das eigelb salz und zucker einfach
schön richtig richtig cremig verrühren
dann müsst ihr auch keine eier trennen
also wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr
natürlich wenn jetzt keine keine kids
schnitt oder keine küchenmaschine habt
könnt ihr gerne die eier trennen und das
eiweiß separat aufschlagen dann geht es
da ein bisschen schneller aber wenn ihr
eine küchenmaschine habt dann brauchte
die einig trennen da könnt ihr einfach
alles zusammen hier in der maschine
verrühren und dann wird es auch schön
cremig und luftig
[Musik]
und gibt hier auch gern schon die
zuckerpaste dazu
[Musik]
die mutter sitzt geschmolzen und da gebe
ich jetzt gleich dekorateure rein damit
sie einfach in der restwärme schmilzt
die reicht dann auch wirklich komplett
aus und was ich dazu sagen muss es so
viel kann natürlich nur so gut schmecken
so gut wie eure schokolade ist denn ich
habe wirklich eigentlich einen recht
recht hohen schokoladen anteil ich
benutze er seit über einem jahr schon
die callebaut schokolade und ich bin
auch sehr zufrieden mit ihr weil sie
einfach sehr gut schmeckt und die
qualität eben gut ist deswegen achtet
hierbei um so viele einfach auf eine
gute schokoladen qualität das wollte ich
noch sagen und was sie jetzt auch gleich
in der zwischenzeit machen könnt während
das hier gleich noch weiter rührt ihr
könnt euch dann schon mal ofen förmchen
nehmen entweder nimmt ihr kleines
schälchen wenn ihr habt ich habe auch
zum beispiel diese hier das sind auch
soviel schälchen die sind backofenfest
weil sie aus borosilikatglas
aber auch wenn ihr ein geschirr set habt
was eben auch hitze nicht so empfindlich
ist sondern hitzebeständig ist wie zb
dieses high temperature porzellan im
porzellan könnt ihr auch immer alles im
backofen garen also das könnt ihr auch
gern machen und ich mache das jetzt
gleich in diesen espresso förmchen weil
ich die von der größe her ganz süß finde
falls ihr es größer machen wollte gerne
auch sonst so viel steinchen so jetzt
nimm dir einfach euer geschick und könnt
nämlich die ruhezeit noch ausnutzen und
das geschirr mit back trends bei
ausfällen oder mit flüssiger butter und
mit zucker ausstreuen falls es dann
später nämlich umkippen und also raus
schützen wollte
[Musik]
so sieht die masse perfekt aus als ihr
seht schon richtig schön dickflüssig und
cremig und genau so soll es auch sein da
kommt da die flüssige schokolade butter
langsam dazu
kurz unterheben und da auch wirklich
schön vorsichtig
und weil ich jetzt wirklich extrem viel
luft eingeschlagen habe und das ganze
schön cremig ist brauche ich jetzt auch
kein backpulver sondern kann ganz
normales mail verwenden und das dazu 7
und am besten nimmt euch jetzt einen
spritzbeutel und füllt die so viel masse
da rein so kann man sich nämlich schön
portionieren und schön aufteilen ohne
das was daneben klettert aber wir sind
auch ein großes team und alle freuen
sich sehr auf schokoladen soufflé mit
flüssigem kern
ich ganz besonders
man kann ich jetzt gleich mit der
loslegen aber ich hole noch kurz meine
karsch aus dem gefrierfach
meistens nehme ich einfach so eine
küchen klammer hierfür den spritzbeutel
dann stelle ich dann zur seite und
verwende gleich noch aktionäre von den
kleinen und jetzt könnt ihr euch im
prinzip einfach so eine kleine schälchen
nehmen
die spitze da vorne wegschneiden um ein
film zur ungefähr bis zwei drittel
nicht so voll machen
und dann kommt da eben eine garage kugel
rein
die sorgt später dafür dass es wirklich
immer schön flüssig bleibt
und sobald die alle gefüllt sind kommen
sie sowieso ins gefrierfach dann wird
das soufflé nämlich schon fest oder kann
man es jederzeit zu bereiten das heißt
ihr müsst doch nicht in der küche stehen
und auf den punkt genau das soufflé
zubereiten sondern ihr könnt einfach
vorbereiten und einfrieren hat einen
gezielten abend und dann kam es in den
backofen
ich glaube sie gerne
[Musik]
das kann ich dir schon mal einfrieren
und dann noch eine helle version für
euch machen
für euch und für uns besteht sich
für die helle masse nämlich 55 eigelb
150 gramm zucker eine prise salz und
etwas vanille extrakt jeweils 100 gramm
butter und weiße kuvertüre
250 gramm quark 100 gramm mehl und eine
zitrone davon brauche ich nämlich den
abrieb ich habe jetzt schon für die
helle version eine garage gestellt und
habe dafür einfach sahne aufkochen
lassen den herd ausgeschaltet und dann
eben die weiße kuvertüre eingerührt
umgefüllt und das ganze jetzt
eingefroren das heißt die garage ist
einfach schon mal bereit der flüssige
kern ist sicher dann nehme ich jetzt
hier auch eigentlich die gleiche
vorgehensweise bei zucker salz und
vanille wird dann schön cremig verrührt
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich die
butter schmelzen und die kuvertüre
dazugeben bei geringer hitze
dann habe ich die masse hier auch fertig
er wundert euch übrigens hat meinen papa
da steht da hinten und macht gerade
essen der macht gerade eine zwiebel
salat und lange spiesse denn der murat
hat heute beschlossen dass wir den grill
anschmeißen für das ganze team und da
ich mein papa dann sofort dabei da macht
ja immer so eine lange spiesse sohn hier
ist eigentlich auch wie vorhin schon
hier würde ich aber den quark einfach
noch mit in die mutter masse einrühren
damit der nicht so flott und dann auch
alles unterheben und gern mit etwas
zitrone abrieb verfeinern und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr hier aber auch gerne
zum beispiel ein bisschen kokos likör
dazu geben oder auch andere liköre um
das ganze zu verfeinern wenn ihr möchtet
und was man auch ganz gut machen kann
statt einem ghanas kern einfach einen
ukas camp wenn ihr nougat nennt und den
mit rein habt ihr auch schön flüssigen
hirn so gut ich hab grad eigentlich zum
ein paar bugs tag kommen ich mache die
zwiebeln durch die maschine durch
schneidegeräte ich bin die maschine
als erstes lieber selber
ich liebe salat passt sogar zum hier
wird gerade die hunger aber noch nicht
auf so flair sondern jetzt auf den
zwiebeln salat von papa
es kommt noch alles kommt alles gut also
ich hab jetzt hier schon ein schönes
zitronen so fleht denn ich habe wirklich
die ganze zitronenschale reingegangen
wäre das nicht möchte da macht er
einfach nur eine prise rein oder gar
nichts davon jetzt
hier auch schön reinfallen ich mag so
kleine portionen weil da kann man auch
ganz schön dass du immer hier und da
kann man nämlich ganz schön so ein
dessertteller machen und kann dann zum
beispiel noch eine kugel eis dazu
servieren waren wir schon kochen
was kommt man da noch mehr
[Musik]
die garage ist es noch nicht ganz fest
aber jetzt ist halt so ich kann keine
praline formen aber alles gut ich habe
dir nicht lange genug eingefroren denn
die männer stressen mich gerade die
wollen jetzt draußen grill ich lasse
mich von dem stress nicht anstecken mach
das schön weiter in ruhe aber habe ich
einen kleinen fehler
[Musik]
egal das wird schon das wird schon
funktionieren
1 der verwirrung den videos schokosoße
erwartet man bekommt einen salat
sorgt papa ist jetzt noch die
zitronenschale
genau nix verschwenden
gut ich würde sagen mutter mit geht's
erst mal grillen sonst kommen wir mit
dem senat weiter ich glaub mir gehen
erstmal alle grillen danach gibt es so
viele dass mir erst mal einfrieren
[Musik]
dieses video beschreibt einfach so mein
leben ich habe schon so viel geplant und
dann war lahm spiel ist grillen
timo rath monats finger die verletzung
der grill dennis alles zusammen ok
jedenfalls habe ich jetzt hier
total philosophie auf vorrat ich werde
die meisten wieder einfrieren fürs team
das er uns einfach jeden tag immer wenn
wir lust haben an den backofen schieben
können jedenfalls kommen die jetzt bei
180 grad ober unterhitze in den backofen
uns kommt halt jetzt echt drauf an was
für einen ofen vor benutzt also wenn ihr
jetzt zum beispiel so eine größere form
habt back dir natürlich etwas länger
wenn ihr kleine tassen haken die etwas
kürzer ich schätze jetzt mal zwölf bis
vierzehn minuten für die tassen ihr
könnt doch immer ganz gerne um
sicherzugehen einfach nur eine tasse
erstmal im backofen stellt und
ausprobieren so als referenz und dann
habt ihr die backzeit für alle das heißt
ich brauche jetzt einfach ein paar
schuhe und ein paar helle fleck und dann
werden wir die ganze probieren mich
ärgert ist nicht nur ein bisschen mit
dem schoko kern da aber das wird schon
gutgehen glaube nicht
[Musik]
deshalb lese fertig hat jetzt ein
bisschen länger gebacken aber wie gesagt
kein stress denn im innern ist es so
oder so noch flüssig von entweder können
das jetzt aus dem aus dem aus der tasse
rausnehmen oder in der tasse servieren
so gewollt dass jetzt mal gucken ob ich
hab's nicht gut eingeführt hat wie es
uns aus der
tasse
bei vista vista wie ich mein kommt
hätte sind richtig
vor allem finde ich dass mir zum mini
mini tassen ich halt auch schwierig dann
aber ihr könnt sie auch gern vorher
besser fetten und raus stürzen
sich dass eine stürze oder lassen
ja
ich denke schon richtig die zitrone
der flüssige kern
[Musik]
das gut mit zitrone lässt du
wahrscheinlich in dem soviel laden
ich weiß was richtig lecker war
[Musik]
zwar nur so in meiner vorstellung
heute ist erstmal
gut gehört dass hier mit zitrone lecker
schmecker
das lecker
teilt seine kugel eis dazu familie und
der hier
könnte einfach dieses blitzschneller
eismachen aus tk früchten einfach ein
esslöffel joghurt oder mascarpone dazu
bis in puderzucker vor mixen fertig dann
habt ihr das perfekte dass er ein schoko
soufflé oder ein helles zitronen soufflé
im handumdrehen aus dem tiefkühlfach gut
vorbereitet und ich sag's euch da seid
ihr echter hit auf jeder party ja jetzt
können das schön euer date beeindrucken
[Gelächter]
also probiert gerne mal aus hell oder
dunkel
schreibt mir gerne was euer favorit ist
[Musik]